bonjour petit peu plus des chanteurs net
je suis avec six fans au bonjour lice
julien que vous connaissez sûrement de
cyrano et si vous connaissez pas et ben
ça va être une bonne occasion de le
rencontrer merci d'être là ça cool tu
merci à toi je viens je t'ai rencontrée
grâce à tes vidéos que tu faisais sur
zelda il y avait deux trois vidéos sur
le sujet quelques sud quelques unes si
peu et là sur ta chaîne je viens
d'essayer de déduire quelque chose en
rapport avec zelda exactement je vais
vous expliquer comment j'ai fait pour
que vous puissiez vous aussi essayer de
le refaire mais pour ça il faut
absolument que vous commencez par
regarder la vidéo qui est sur la chaîne
de julien je vous mets le lien dans la
description et dès que vous avez fait ça
vous revenez vous remettez ici je vais
mettre le time code de la reprise et
vous aurez l'explication mais ce serait
un peu nul de regarder l'explication
avant de voir ce qui s'y passe ouais
voilà merci madame
et après ils peuvent retourner la voir
avec des explications nécessaires pour
avoir la vision différente
vous ne sortirez jamais exercé d'un
vidéo évidemment on va on va reprendre à
zéro
j'étais devenue une bibliothèque de
symboles exactement où il ya de mémoire
donc il ya un cerveau un cercle une
croix des vagues à carey a symbol home
depot mende ou de l'homme est aussi une
étoile ça et je t'ai demandé dans le tas
de d'en choisir un de penser à un oui
c'est le cas je serai toujours le cas et
je vais essayer de retrouver lequel sauf
que là je vais vous commentez au fur à
mesure ce qu'on va fermer que toi tu
avais pressenti déjà dans la première
vidéo c'est qu'on a fait sur ta chaîne
c'est que je me base sur les mouvements
du regard oui mais pas les mouvements
inconscient considère l'intérieur les
mouvements réels puisque comme tu
t'imagines quelque chose pour ça je le
regarde exactement créé par exemple tout
débuts dans ta vidéo je t'ai demandé de
regarder de base en eau
la scène est en fait t'as regardé et a
vraiment mis une ligne basse tesio ne
bougeait pas ouais et apprête à remonter
le regard regards étaient du mal à
arrêter de le monter et ça c'est typique
des scènes qui ont lieu en extérieur
quand c'est en intérieur on s'arrête au
plafond d'accord ensuite je t'avais
demandé de regarder le ou les
personnages
bon alors là c'est une étape serait là
ça fait limite alors là il ya quelqu'un
là y'a quelqu'un il y avait même
différence de taille c'est à dire que
j'aurais une chance de taille
ça a été inconscient je pense à huy bien
sa gérance perdra un futur ensuite on a
fait plusieurs choses on a fait un petit
peu de cul berland 10 mhz alors ça que
ça t'a plu beaucoup donc c'est quand une
prise de pouvoir mais un petit peu
améliorée puisque je vais essayer de
sentir tout les contractions micro
musculaire inconscience il a battu le
sens bien exactement même et on en a
plein des tout petits
le meilleur exemple que je peux donner
sur le cul berlin 10 et quand tu es sur
ton vélo et bien que tu veut dévier un
tout petit peu à droite tu le pense mais
tu ne conscientisent pas de je vais
tourner demeure à peine d'y penser ça
tombe tout seul rêve et ça c'est du
micro mouvements par exemple frank et
moi j'essaie de ressentir les réactions
je vous mets une fiche le pari six ans
au vert une vidéo que j'avais fait sur
le cube irlande isme avec un pote qui
s'appelle noam s'est entraîné à avoir
les sensations d'accord ce serait
effectivement comme ça tu es quand je
bouge je sens effectivement en dessous
et dans l'idéal pas d'accord que l'autre
personne lll
elle pose vraiment comme elle pousserait
sur une table vraiment lourdement tu as
le sens vers là tu le sens et c'est
effectivement tout se sentir comme ça
d'accord avec un mouvement conscience tu
vas oui c'est à dire quand et cède pas
bougé pour arriver à se sentir dans de
la vidéo en question de que vous pourrez
aller voir donne vraiment des exercices
d'entraînement par exemple au départ il
ya deux objets demande à la personne
doit choisir un dans sa tête
es tu passé tu compare les sensations
vraiment commencé à boire étape quoi tu
veux et bien sûr comme le mec qui
voudraient commencer à courir et le
lendemain faire un marathon bess island
il faut voilà étape par étape
alors ce symbole on va essayer de
retrouver là c'est compliqué parce que
c'est pas des éléments comme tout à fait
est ce que tu peux le regarder devant
toi c'est à dire comme s'il était devant
toi tu peux le voir je le vois ok
maintenant je te parle déjà d'une base
imagine qu'il ya un panneau comme ça
devant les liens et je vais essayer de
jouer un peu avec les formes de ce
panneau et toi tu regarde ce que fait
mon doigt et juste eu commandes dans ta
tête par exemple qu'il qui maintient
larguées sur sur la bonne forme ou pas
la bonne forme ce genre de choses qu'on
a là par exemple je sais qu'il ya des
choses qui sont plutôt arrondies comme
ça tu vois je sais que c'est en activant
dans tous les sens comme ça et tout
tu peux regarder de nouveau ton dessin
virtuel tu l du coup je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait de forme circulaire dans ton
dessin est ce que j'ai bon tu as bon ok
ce qui me permet d'éliminer pour moi le
cerveau le cercle oui
potentiellement le symbole hindous aussi
le home qui est bourré de choses comme
ça
potentiellement je te dis car tu ne
seras jamais rien tu verras bien je te
demander de regarder le côté du dessin
qui est le plus à gauche donc sur ton
dessin tu regardes le côté quai le plus
à gauche mettant le côté quai le plus à
droite
ok là au regard on a eu oui une libre
donc j'ai une vie je pense que tu as
suivi ton tracé naturel au tracé du
descente unis je pense peut être encore
une fois on s'inquiète on n'est pas bien
sûr et je vais finir tient mais pas qu
berlin 10 mhz comme ça t'as plus quand
je dirais le nom de ton dessin tu dira
oui mais dans ta tête
ok en forme il y avait le cerveau il y
avait certes il y avait le carré il y
avait la croix il y avait les sorties
de vagues il y avait le rom il a fait
ces étoiles très nettes même un truc un
peu plus rectangulaire et je pense que
j'ai le tient je le dessine vas-y
dessine me chercher un crayon jedessine
allez je sens qu'il va me faire pression
parce que je trouve que j'ai ouvert ma
bouche un peu rapidement les amuse
beaucoup beaucoup et non pourquoi tu
puises elias et je vois ça tu vois ça
use
je l'est parce que je montre aux gens
d'avoir le dessin ou non non on va
devoir maintenant ok moi aussi je veux
sur des petits détails au mouvement du
crayon que tu as fait je pense que tu
repasser plusieurs fois au même endroit
ah oui et donc je pense je pense que tu
retrouves c'est vrai je pense qu on le
monte il a fait de la déduction elle te
fait un deux trois oui mais c'est bon
c'est bon
et oui parce que tu as tu as fait comme
ça donc j'ai exact à dire jouer
effectivement la croix la barre tu m'a
dit regarde à gauche avant elle fait
boum comme ça j'aime et tu sais que
avant lui que tu le dises je les ressens
teaser je suis à temps mais j'ai fait un
truc trop nativement le dire c'est
obligé alors en fait tu pensais que ce
serait plus compliqué pour moi avec des
formes qu'avec des photos un traitement
en réalité c'est plus simple pourquoi
parce que j'ai pas pris ses formes au
hasard et je vais vous mettre un pdf
vous pourrez les télécharger dans la
description
j'ai pris des formes qui vraiment
permettre de faire des éliminations
franches comme ça vous pouvez vous
entraîner à essayer de le faire sur
quelqu'un en prenant des séquences
pareil en essayant d'éliminer vous
pouvez reprendre à peu près les mêmes
délires et quand vous commencez à avoir
des pistes l'idée par exemple l'âge
savait assez rapidement que c'était
entre le carré et lacroix et belhache et
j'ai fait faire de gauche à droite pour
voir quel serait son mouvement en fait
de regard et tu t'es centrer pour
regarder à gauche et après en gare y
aurais je la mettrais au chalet oui je
me suis allé vous avez le fichier vous
pouvez télécharger vous entraîner avec
ça vous avez aussi le lien vers la vidéo
sur le libéralisme plus important vous
avez encore le lien avec la vidéo de
cyrano que vous pouvez revoir maintenant
que vous connaissez les astuces vous
pouvez encore la revoir et vous
comprendre ce qu'ils aient au niveau du
regard à ce moment là n'oubliez pas la
date de l'olympia vous avez damman
info le lien dans la description vers la
boutique le livre le jeu tout ça toi
même cuisse et joue kif laisser un pouce
en l'air abonnez vous j'ai l'impression
d'être jean claude van damme
ciao bye et là peut être que vos yeux
sont directement à tirer vers le premier
cercle où le deuxième cercle d'ailleurs
parce qu'il ya deux abonnements et oui à
désabonnement monnaies ou deux fois plus
de plaisir ça s à mon gars c'est de la
déduction et je vais faire une chaîne de
mentalisme
[Musique]